-We'll be right back with
a performance from Dayglow.
Stick around!
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's amazing.
♪♪
How is your vinyl collection?
-It's good. It's good.
-Is it anywhere near Questlove's
vinyl collection?
-Here's the thing.
I feel like I have a collection.
Questlove has a problem.
-Yeah, really.
-He's a hoarder.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I have a
healthy collection of records.
I think Questlove is a hoarder.
I think what we have right now
is an opportunity
to have an intervention,
where we all just take
some records away from him.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-No.
This actually isn't even an
audience, Questlove.
-No. These are all just
music friends who were like,
"We each need to take
like 100 records
out of your collection
just to get you back to
a healthy place."
-Just 100?
-Yeah, just 100 each.
-Okay, cool.
-Yeah.
-Do you get flashbacks still
when you come into
this building?
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
No, I mean, I've been
in this building
since I was 19 years old.
-Yeah, I've known you for,
gosh, probably
has to be 20 years.
-Yeah, well, I mean, I'm 78.
-Oh, my gosh!
You look fantastic.
-Thank you very much. Yeah.
-Wow. That's great.
-I was moisturizing a lot
this pandemic.
-You auditioned to be
a writer on "SNL," right?
-I did, yeah. I interviewed.
I actually interviewed
with Tina.
-Wow!
-And I had probably
the worst interview a
person could have.
'Cause here's the thing.
When I got the job --
When I interviewed for the job,
I didn't have an agent.
It was just through their --
'cause I had interned here
when I was 19.
And then Mike Shoemaker
and Colin Quinn
had suggested me as a writer
because Colin had read
some of my sketches and stuff.
And, so, I came in, and because
I didn't have an agent,
I didn't know what to do
and I didn't know
what to expect.
And, so, the only person
I could talk to was
my stepfather,
who just works in, like,
the accounting department
for an airline in Texas.
And he was like,
"Well, you know,
it's a job interview,
so you need to treat it
like a job interview.
But it's not a real job,
because it's TV,
so you don't need
to wear, like, a suit,
but maybe wear, like,
khaki slacks and a blazer
and carry a little briefcase."
And that's what I did.
-What?!
-You came in with a briefcase?
-I came in with
a little briefcase.
-What was in the briefcase?
-Just my plane ticket.
My plane ticket and probably
a "Highlights" magazine.
But I came in and I looked like
I was coming in for a bank loan.
And I remember
I sat across from Tina
and a bunch of
the other writers.
And they're all having fun,
and Tina is
just trying to, like,
get me to show my personality.
And I'm just answering
everything like, "Uh-huh.
Yes.
No, ma'am. Yes, ma'am.
Sure, ma'am."
-Oh, my gosh.
-"That's the door, ma'am?
Okay."
-"Okay. Bye, ma'am."
-"Bye, ma'am."
-"See you never."
-Yeah.
Well, and then, because I didn't
have an agent, like,
normally,
if you have an agent, like,
your agent follows up for you
and they do all that stuff.
I didn't have that.
The only person I knew who
I could contact at the show
was one of Lorne's assistants.
And so I was just calling
Lorne's assistant like,
"Hey, have you heard
anything about the show?"
And, like, Lorne's assistant --
like, to me,
that was the most powerful
person I knew at the show,
but, like, an assistant isn't
the most powerful person
at a show.
And he -- poor guy --
was just like,
"Yeah, man, I think you're
still in the mix.
Like, I'll put in
a good word for you."